there's already more than half a million
drones that have been registered in the
US there's nothing quite like a flying
robot delivering a package into your
hands within minutes of placing an order
that is a magical experience that
magical experience isn't as far away as
you might think
flirty is the first company to get
government approval to make deliveries
by drone beating out Amazon and Google
DZ IP are you ready to go
okay we are clear and ready for you to
deliver we're in the desert outside of
Reno Nevada at a secret site where the
small start-up regularly tests its
delivery drones and what is the scenario
we're thinking about today tell us about
that what what the customer application
of this would be so the customer
application is simple you open your
smart phone you push a button in order
to order over-the-counter medicine we
load up a package
they take off vertically they fly based
on predefined GPS coordinates to the
customers home location or smartphone
location and then when the customers
ready to receive the delivery the drone
hovers at about fifty feet which is
above trees above buildings and above
power line so it was that 100 feet
before and now it's coming down to 45
feet to hover and lower the package to
us we've designed custom packaging to
ensure that cold food stays cold hot
food stays hot and delicate foods stay
unbroken so Spencer another flirty drone
delivery chili dog here Hey bismuth here
exactly
we then fly back and land autonomously
where we took off from reload the drone
and conduct that delivery again all the
testing in the desert is paying off
flirty drones are already delivering
Domino's Pizza in New Zealand and in
July flirty teamed up with 7-eleven to
make the first drone delivery of
over-the-counter medicine to a
customer's home in the United States
when we're operating in a neighborhood
near you we'll be able to deliver to you
within 10 minutes of you placing an
order we've designed and built our
drones to carry up to five and a half
pounds for up to ten miles there
hexacopters powered by lithium polymer
batteries so they're electrically
powered green aircraft
right now flirty is beating the tech
goliaths and drone delivery the next
step is turning that head started to
profit to do that Matt Sweeney will have
to convince a lot of shoppers that a
magical experience of a box dropped from
the sky is worth the premium delivery
thing why does society new drone
delivery if you're hungry would you want
your pizza delivered by drone or or by
cars during peak hour traffic and if
your kids are sick would you want the
over-the-counter medicine delivered from
7-eleven within 10 minutes by flirting
or would you prefer load your kids into
a car at night and take them down into
the storm and within several years
drone delivery will be as common as
seeing a truck delivering packages on
the street today